well this is Benford's law and it's
about numbers but it's about the leading
digit for example you could look at the
populations of all the countries in the
world and look at the leading digits of
all those so for example if it was 1269
then the leading digit in that cases is
the one
Memphis law works on a distribution of
numbers if that distribution spans quite
a few orders of magnitude and the
brilliant thing about populations of
countries is it actually goes from tens
of civilians if you were to think about
that okay what are the distribution of
leading digits so some of the
populations will start with one song
will start with two three four five six
seven eight or nine and so there are
nine possible leading digits and you
might imagine that each one of those
possible leading digits are equally
likely to appear so that's one in nine
eleven percent and if I was to plot that
on a graph you might expect that to
fluctuate around 11% so it's going to
sort of you know go that so what
actually happens is that a third of the
time that's up here right a third of the
time the number you choose will start
with a 1 and it will hardly ever start
with a nine so nine is kind of like down
here you know tying of it and then you
get this brilliant curve it goes up like
that it's not crazy I know you talk
about this sometimes and talks and
things you do what's the reaction to
that normally when you tell people this
the reaction okay they're not noise is
sort of this and there's a certain route
disbelieves sometimes as well the way we
do actually in the show is that we get
people to tweet numbers to us so we're
collecting numbers and I try to make it
I try to give them ideas so maybe like
take the distance from the venue to
where they live and convert that into
some strange units or something like
that the interesting thing is it like I
was saying it works so long as the
distribution you're choosing from spans
loads of orders of magnitude but if
you're picking numbers from lots of
different distributions the individual
distributions don't have to span lots of
orders of magnitude the this sort of the
meta distribution of individual things
pick from different distributions
follows Benford's though anyway so it's
a it's a works it works pretty well
number of numbers will this not work for
human height in meters so humans are
between you know 1 meter and 3 meter
tall so it doesn't work for that you get
you know you get a massive load around
around there and and you know no one's 9
meters so anything that has that kind of
short distribution that it doesn't work
for but it does work for several
distributions put together that don't
necessarily individually foot follow the
rules so I did it idea for populations I
did it for areas of countries in
kilometer squared if you take one number
and convert it to loads of different
units that will tend to follow both of
those well you do it for the financial
time so look at all the numbers on the
front cover the financial time day will
tend to follow Memphis tour as well
just a quick interjection you can also
apply this to the number of times you
watch numberphile videos or leave
comments underneath more information at
the end of the video so the explanation
it is to do with scale invariance which
I'm just getting my head round now but
there are a couple of intuitive ways of
understanding it one of them is to use
the idea of a raffle to begin with it's
a very small raffle okay so there are
only two tickets in this raffle what are
the chances of the winning ticket in
this raffle having a leading digit of
one well that's this one so it's 1 in 2
it's 50% but then if you increase the
size of the raffle there are now three
tickets in the raffle the chances now
are one in three or about 33% if you add
a fourth ticket then the probability of
the leading digit of the winning ticket
being a 1 is now 25 percent and then 20
percent and so on and so on until you
have a raffle with their 9 tickets in it
and then the probability of the winning
ticket having leading digit 1 is 1 and 9
it's 11 percent which was the kind of
intuitive thing that you might think but
then you add your tenth ticket and now
there are two tickets that start with a
1 so now the probability is 2 in 10 or 1
+ 5 so it go back up to 20% the
probability will go up and up and up as
you add more tickets let's start with up
with a 1 and once you have a
for with 19 tickets in it you're up to
something like 58% and then you add the
20th ticket and so the probability goes
down again so the probability of the
winning ticket having leading digit of
one will go down and down it down
through the 20s it'll go down through
the 40s down through the 50s 60s 70s 80s
90s until you add the hundredth ticket
and then the probability will start to
go up again and then probably to go up
and up and up and up all the way through
the hundreds and then you get to the
200s and it goes down and down and down
through all the 200 strangers four
hundred six hundred seven hundred eight
hundred nine hundreds and you'll be back
to eleven percent again then and then
you add the thousandth ticket the
probability will start to go over again
the problems goes up and up and up
through the thousands and then down
through two thousand three thousand five
over and then you get to ten thousand
goes up and so basically the probability
of the winning ticket having leading
digit of one fluctuates as the size of
the raffle increases and so so this is a
log scale of the raffle increasing in
size so you might have a you know at ten
a hundred a thousand ten thousand and so
on and then this is the probability here
of the ticket having in digit of one it
will it will sort of go it sort of goes
like that what Frank Benford realized
was that if you pick a number from a
distribution that spans loads of orders
of magnitude or if you pick a number
from the world and you don't necessarily
know what the distribution is in advance
then it's like picking a ticket from a
raffle when you don't know the size of
the raffle so you have to take the
average of this wiggly line which is
what he did so that's the average there
and it's around thirty percent there's a
formula for it which is the probability
of picking a number with a particular
leading digit of D is equal to log to
base 10 of 1 plus 1 over D like that and
so that's how you do it and if you plug
one into there then it's log base 10 of
2 and it ends up being about 30 percent
the beauty is
that you could do it in any base so this
doesn't have to be base 10 it could be
base 5
you know base 16 whatever you want to do
and so you can apply them to those
different bases this is a formula that
they use Freight a forensic accountant
would use so tax fraud or something like
that if you're making up numbers in your
accounts and the numbers you make up
don't follow Benford's or then that's a
clue that you might be cheating so this
is a number you need to this is a
formula you need to remember if you're
going to cheat on your tax return
a lot of a lot of things that sort of
mathematically inclined people like
yourself tell me when I hear about them
sort of seem counterintuitive and then
you cleverly explain why it works the
way it works this is one of the few
things that when I've heard about it
this just seems logical to me like when
someone says one will come up more often
yeah to me that just seemed like of
course that would happen yes funny isn't
it so some people are like you I would
say you're in the minority of people
that go yeah and I wonder if there is
another sort of intuitive way of looking
at it that you've tapped into which is
that if you imagine something like the
Nasdaq index or something like that and
I don't know what the Nasdaq index is
size wise but imagine that it's the
Nasdaq index is at a thousand to change
that to two thousand you would have to
double it so the Nasdaq enos would have
to increase by a hundred percent to get
from something that starts with one to
something that starts with a two so
that's quite a big change but if the
Nasdaq index was on nine thousand and
you wanted to increase it to ten
thousand then that's an 11 percent
increase so it's hardly anything so
basically you don't really hang around
the nines as things are growing and
shrinking you don't hang around whereas
you do hang around the ones and maybe
that's intuitive to you and so you like
me obviously if you'd like to see even
more about Benford's law we've done bit
of a statistical analysis to find out
whether or not your viewing habits and
the number of times you comment on
numberphile videos is following the
Benford curve the link is below this
video or
here on the screen so why don't you
check it out